hey guys it is the sixth of much my name
is Jess and we swapped hosts again to
keep you on your toes here's news first
up get ready to turn the lights up and
the sound down because out last two has
a release date the follow up to 2013
outlast will arrive on ps4 xbox one and
pc in just over a month on april 25 if
you want caught up on the series the
outlast Trinity is also out on April 25
the physical bundle includes outlast and
it's whistleblower expansion as well as
out last 2 the sequel was originally
slated to arrive at the end of 2016
before it was delayed too early this
year if you cannot quite wait that long
you can get in the spooky mood with some
tracks from out last 2 soundtrack in our
story on site Bioware have given us a
little more information about the Mass
Effect Andromeda trial that is arriving
ahead of the game's release for EA and
origin access subscribers the developer
has said that while you can play as much
multiplayer as you like the
single-player access is limited producer
Fernando melo explained on Twitter you
can play the trial all in single player
if you want but it is gated you can't
continue the story after a point but can
explore restart for example this is
generally what we've seen before from EA
and origin access trials battlefield one
also offered up unlimited multiplayer
access but only a few single player
missions for subscribers and before it's
official release miller also tastes a
new feature in Andromeda called missions
which links single and multiplayer
Andromeda's trial will go live on much
16 for Xbox one and PC while the game is
out on lunch 21 for pc ps4 and xbox one
no version of EA access is available on
ps4 looks like the nintendo switch is
off to a strong start selling twice as
many launch consoles as the wii u in the
UK games industry derbez has reported
that the console sold around 80,000
units over the weekend double that of
the wii u's 40,000 units sold at launch
in twenty twelve comparatively the 3d s
veld 113,000 units at launch in the UK
xbox one sold a hundred and fifty
thousand units
the ps4 sold 250,000 units the switch
sales numbers are not verified by
Nintendo as the publisher are yet to
officially announce any sales figures
for their latest console in related news
rather the wild with the second
best-selling game of the week in the UK
just behind horizon zero dawn almost
eighty percent of those zelda copies
sold were on switch considering how many
people have ps4s in comparison to such
as that's pretty impressive that is
everything I've got for you today do
leave me a comment in that comment box
head to gamespot for all our latest news
and features subscribe to us if you like
the video and I will see you tomorrow